it is rooted in a number of things
firstly we are predominantly Christian
country and a fervent Christian country
it may not be reflected entirely in
terms of how we or we live sometimes but
we are passionately committed to certain
basic Christian principles which which
has true homosexuality but we have
become quite tolerant we are tolerant
provided that homosexual lifestyle does
not invade our space and what I what do
I mean by that persons who wish because
of their own intonation to live in a
homosexual relationship I do so in
Jamaica and there are many many such
persons in Jamaica the society in
Jamaica in general do not want to be do
not want it to be flaunted they don't
want it to be sort of thrown in the face
because there are some real fears their
real fears the basic unit of a society
is a family and there is a passionate
concern in Jamaica about protecting the
integrity of the family and it is felt
that encouragement or or recognition of
the appropriateness of a homosexual
lifestyle is going to undermine the
effectiveness of that family unit and in
that process undermined the basic fabric
of a society but I think much of what
has been carried in the international
media in terms of homophobia in Jamaica
is grossly exaggerated the homosexual is
in Jamaica they live they enjoy their
relationship they they are intermingle
with heterosexuals they have normal
relations with heterosexual but they do
have their private relationship and so
long as that is so I don't believe that
a peep
Jamaica are going to be particularly
perturbed what is illegal in Jamaica is
it Walker Bush is in fact making
homosexual acts illegal there have been
very very few prosecutions very very few
and in most instances where there are
prosecutions this is because there's a
complaint by a victim so that it not
it's not the flashpoint issue that many
people in international media claim that
it is